okay welcome back to class everyone
today is Wednesday and that means that
the midterm comes out today so I will
upload it to the course website right
after class when I get back to my office
I've also posted homework three which is
due on next Friday okay so the midterm
will be due at 4:00 p.m. this Friday in
two days and the third homework will be
due a week from this Friday also at 4:00
p.m. any questions about the midterm or
anything before I post it yeah whatever
one feel better if I made the deadline 5
p.m. yeah I mean I'm fine with 5 p.m.
that's that's totally fine with me you
should try to get it in by 4 p.m. so you
can make happy hour
so I can make happy hour but 5 p.m.
would be fine
I did post the 3rd homework so let's see
so the 3rd homework is a little bit
involved because this is kind of a two
week homework even though I'm giving you
a we can have to do it you have to
define derive the 2d laplacian in polar
coordinates you also have to solve
Laplace's equation on a 2d disc with
boundary conditions using separation of
variables this is not too difficult you
have to do heat conduction in a thin
circular ring so we've been doing heat
conduction in a 1d bar now imagine you
take that bar and you bend it into a
circle so that the boundary conditions
are that the temperature and the flux
have to match essentially at 0 and 2pi
and then I have one last problem which
is about the Fourier transform so you're
gonna do the Fourier series by hand and
and stuff okay so if this seems a little
long and maybe a little bit difficult
having two partial differential
equations on the homework just remember
that I didn't put these on the midterm
and I was this close I decided to give
you a different PDE on the midterm
that's a little bit more like what we've
seen in class okay that's all I have for
intro stuff I've also posted lectures 13
and 14 and I'm gonna I'm gonna post
lecture 15 soon other logistical things
I'm gonna be out of town next Wednesday
and Friday but I think I'm actually
going to take video lectures that I've
already recorded and post them online so
you can just watch them at home does
everyone know how to log on to the video
lectures yeah okay
so I've decided to mix things up a
little bit I was going to put all of the
data science stuff at the very end of
the course but since I have data science
lectures pre-recorded I'm going to give
a week of the fast Fourier transform
next week okay so we're doing Fourier
series now Fourier transforms on Friday
and Monday and then when I'm gone you'll
have three video lectures that you can
watch okay and this is going to bring us
up to 30 total lectures for the year
which means I don't have to cut any of
the awesome stuff that I was going to
show you okay so I'm going to be
visiting Berlin in Germany and also a
place called bronze Phi to talk about
fluid flow control and data science and
it's kind of fitting that I'm going to
be posting my data science lectures
while I'm gone to a workshop on data
science and we'll see an interesting
German connection in today's lecture
with Hilbert's okay so I'll tell you a
little bit about German history with
Hilbert and girding in which is pretty
interesting okay so what I want to do
today
we've been deriving Fourier series and
we've realized that we can take
basically any function any well
a function that doesn't blow up to
infinity and we can write it as an
infinite sum of sines and cosines on
some finite interval okay now I want to
I've been telling you that functions
form an infinite dimensional vector
space and I've been telling you that the
Fourier series is just a fancy change of
coordinates into a new basis and so I
really want to make this concrete today
and I don't want to go too fast I want
to go from kind of the ground up with
things that we're all very very familiar
with so we all feel comfortable with
vectors in 2d and 3d we have you know
three numbers we can add them we can
multiply them by a scalar we can take
their inner product we know how to take
the norm or the length of a vector and
so we're going to take the concepts of a
vector space and we're going to
essentially show that functions that are
well behaved form a function space an
infinite dimensional vector space and
that this l2 integral formula that we've
been deriving is actually an inner
product in this function space so it
really can be used to determine the
distance between two functions the
reason I want to know what the distance
between two functions is in this
function space is I want to know how
close my approximations are if I have a
fourier series that's infinite maybe in
my computer i can only add up the first
hundred terms in the series or the first
thousand and i want to know how close is
that approximation to my true function
and the only way i can do that is by
introducing kind of a norm of my
function so that's what we're building
up to today we're going to show that
fourier series are a fancy change of
coordinates in an infinite dimensional
vector space called a Hilbert space
Hilbert is from Germany
okay so vector space how many of you
have seen a formal definition of a
vector space before in terms of like
axioms and rules and stuff how many have
not okay good so this is really
important I almost skip this I would
have loved to have been able to skip
this in some sense because it's a little
bit boring but at the same time it's
stuff that you really absolutely should
know this is the foundational you know
vector spaces of the foundation of
almost everything we do in all of the
math and five sixty four and five 65 and
so we have such comfort with vectors
like from the time where babies and from
the time we learned to drive and you
know everything we do we have a
fundamental spatial sense about us we
have intuition about three space and two
space and so it's pretty comfortable for
us to deal with vectors in two and three
space without defining formal
definitions but when we start
generalizing our vector spaces to having
10 or 20 or infinite dimensions we need
to have rules for what makes those
objects like the objects that we're
familiar with okay so that's why we've
been able to get away for so long
without defining what a vector actually
is okay so a vector space is always
defined over a set of numbers either
real numbers or complex numbers okay we
can have functions of a complex number
or functions of a real number and those
are both going to be vector spaces so a
set so a vector space is a set V vectors
that satisfy eight rules okay and when I
list these eight rules I want you to be
thinking about two things are these true
four vectors that we're familiar with
into space and three space you know 2d
and 3d vectors and are they also true
for functions f of X G of X H of X okay
so we have these eight rules and there's
also the notion of addition and
multiplication by a scalar right I can
add two vectors I can multiply a vector
by a scalar these are my scalars right
any number is a scalar okay so think
about if this is true for three vectors
and four functions f of X Y of X no okay
so maybe I'll define some notation
so my vectors are gonna be u V and W my
scalars are gonna be a and B scalars
just mean they're either real or complex
numbers and my vectors also could be you
know my functions might be something
like F G and H I'm telling you that
functions are just fancy vectors ok ok
so the rules that have to be satisfied
for this set of vectors to be called a
vector space is associative
associativity which just means that if I
add u plus V plus W so if I add V plus W
and then I add it to you that's the same
as if I first added u plus V and then
took that vector and added it to W
certainly true of three vectors also
true of functions ok because my function
is defined at a whole set of points X
and this is true at every single one of
those points in X because real numbers
are associative ok the second one is
calm you tivity this just means that my
vectors commute with each other this is
a word that comes up a lot in quantum
mechanics and algebra I got this list
from Wikipedia so you can get it from
Wikipedia too just means that u plus V
is the same as V Plus u it doesn't
matter what order I add these in okay
definitely true for two vectors and
three vectors also true for functions
right sine plus cosine is the same as
cosine cosine okay three is the identity
so the additive identity and what that
means is that there is a zero vector
that when I add it to some vector you
I just get you back so there exists a
zero vector such that you plus zero
equals you these are all vectors I'm
just not going to draw the arrows
because I don't want to I'm only drawing
it here because there's a zero element
of our scalar field also ok I'm
certainly true of vectors also true of
functions right sign plus zero of X is
equal to sign for is we have an additive
inverse which means that for every u
there exists minus u such that u plus
minus u equals my zero vector ok sign
plus minus sign equals zero x squared
plus minus x squared equals zero and
it's interesting the same reason that my
functions satisfy all of these axioms
are the same reason that my vectors do
it's because my three vector really is
composed of three numbers and the
numbers all satisfy these properties
okay so five is a little hard to say
what I call it I'm just going to call
this consistent multiplication
consistent scalar multiplication which
just means if I have my two scalars a
times B times u so I think my scalar
times my vector I just make my vector
longer or shorter and then I do it again
by a that's the same as taking a times B
and multiplying it by my vector u it's a
lot like associativity but it's
associative 'ti of scalar multiplication
okay two more we also have a
duplicative identity is that what it is
yeah multiplicative multiplicative so
what does this mean I multiply my vector
by one I get my vector back okay that's
true of sines and cosines and X
Squared's and any function you can name
okay only two more distributive one and
two okay so the distributive one means
that if I have a scalar times a vector u
plus B so I add U and V and then I
stretch it that's the same as stretching
and stretching you and adding it to what
I get when I stretch V so I can scale
you and then and scale V and then add
them and it's the same as scaling the
addition of u plus V and the last one is
a plus B u equals a u plus B u okay
these are just basic basic rules they
seem a little arbitrary but you can show
that if these rules are true then
everything we know about vectors holds
we can do calculus on vectors on vector
spaces so these are basically the
foundational elements if these are all
true then everything makes sense and the
vector space has basically the same
properties as the vector spaces that
were familiar with so any set of vectors
that satisfy these eight rules act like
the vectors that were used to from to
space in three space that's why we care
about these kind of formal definitions
is because they allow us to take things
that we can't picture in our heads and
say that in some way they're like things
that we can picture
okay so function spaces are certainly
vector spaces because they satisfy all
of these definitions and in most cases
they're pretty trivial how they satisfy
them this is true for all functions any
questions so far about these definitions
pretty clear not so clear why these are
the eight most magical axioms that are
defined what it is to be a vector but
try to think of something that you know
about a two vector or a three vector
that's not on this list that's what
people did that's how they came up with
this list they spent all day in a room
thinking about what properties of my
vector would not be satisfied by this
list and they came up with you know
number four and number seven and then
they came up with number six and number
three and they've eventually filled out
the list and some smart person proved
that you know this is what you need to
be a vector space there's actually no
proof because these are axiomatic okay
so these are what we mean that functions
are also vector spaces and what do we
know that we can do with vectors in a
vector space what did I what's what's
not on this list that I'm just erased no
nothing's on this list what did I not
include in this list that you know is
true about vectors
they have magnitude and direction how do
i quantify the magnitude of a vector how
do I calculate the magnitude of a vector
a norm or
the inner product of it with itself
square root it okay so I need an inner
product I didn't have none of this stuff
tells me that I have an inner product so
an inner product space this is there's a
bunch of definitions an inner product
face is just a vector space with an
inner product it sounds simple okay
vector space with inner product super
simple okay so an inner product is just
a function that takes two vectors and it
returns a scalar okay it's a function
that takes two vectors and it returns a
scalar either a real number or a complex
number right think about this in three
space if I have a vector F and a vector
G and I take their dot product their
inner product it just gives me a number
right so it takes any two vectors and it
gives me a number that number could be
real or complex I don't care okay and
there's a couple of rules that have to
be true for this just like in vector
spaces there's a rule that just call
this rule one is that F inner product G
has to be equal to the complex conjugate
of G inner product with F so if F and G
are real vectors and my inner product
wraps maps to a real number then what is
this just G inner product with F there
is no imaginary part okay so this is
equal to G and our product with F if
real valued so I only need this fancy
conjugate if I'm dealing with complex
vector spaces what doesn't matter okay
and this also makes sense right if I
take a dot B it should be the same as B
dot a right okay we also have what's
known as linearity which means if I have
my number a times F paired with G
that's the same as my number times F
Paradis G I say paired with sometimes
this is just from like quantum mechanics
these are a pair a vector pair an inner
product pair
you also have F plus G inner product
with H is equal to F inner product H
plus G inner product H again think if
this makes sense for three dimensional
vectors certainly [ __ ] right if I have a
plus B if I have two vectors a plus B
and I adopt them with C it's the same as
a dot C plus B dot C these are also true
for functions when I define what this
inner product is for functions you're
going to be able to verify that these
are all true okay and the last one is
that this inner product is basically
never negative okay so this is linearity
and this is non negativity
what's another definition for non
negative like a Mathieu way of saying
non-negative positive definite
yeah positive positive definite is what
we say so if I take the inner product of
F with itself this is always greater
than or equal to zero it's never
negative it's always non-negative and
when can it possibly be equal to zero
it's only equal to zero when F is the
zero vector okay that was great we spent
a few minutes 20 minutes defining vector
spaces over real and complex numbers and
inner product spaces so now we know
mathematically what an inner product is
and this totally jives with what we know
about vectors into space and three space
this is these are all true for vectors
into space in three space this is also
true for functions in my function space
so we're going to define our L two inner
product space
for functions and I've already shown
that functions form a vector space they
satisfy all of our eight definitions
pretty much automatically and so now
what we need to do is define what is the
inner product of two functions okay so
the inner product of two functions if I
have f of X and G of X the L to inner
product is defined by the integral now
these are four functions on interval
defined from A to B so this is sometimes
called l2 of a comma B remember when we
do Fourier series this might be minus PI
to PI or 0 to 2 pi or minus L to L we're
gonna define functions on some interval
so this is the integral from A to B of f
of X times G of X conjugates DX now
again what if my functions are real
valued then I can get rid of this
conjugate it's just f of X G of X that's
it super simple inner product I just
integrate the product of my two
functions that's the inner product of
two functions that's how they dot
products this is the dot product of two
functions I multiply them I integrate
them over my domain I get a number out
satisfies all of those properties you
can verify that definitely satisfies the
first one if I just switch the two of
these and conjugates then it's equal if
I multiply by an A then that a pops out
of the integral if I have F plus H times
G then I can you know split those up
because point wise for every X they
split up so all of these are true ok the
only one that's not so true is property
3 but then again that's also pretty
obvious because F squared is
non-negative over all X
okay any questions about what this inner
product means or or why we're defining
it
I mean I'll ask why are we defining the
center product so we're defining this
inner product because the inner product
allows us to tell how close two vectors
are so if I want to know okay so what is
a how do I tell how close a vector is to
another vector or how how long a vector
is how long the difference vector is so
you've already answered this before
that's the norm of the vector so if I
have an inner product I can define a
norm in two space or three space for
normal vectors what is my norm I have
the norm of a vector you the two norm
what is that
we're root of the sum of the squares
right it's some square root of x squared
plus y squared plus Z squared
and what's x squared plus y squared plus
Z squared inner product with itself so
this is the inner product of U with u to
the one-half power that's exactly how
we're going to define the norm of our
function okay so this is for normal
three vectors you know are three if we
want to do this for norm on a function
this is in some Hilbert space then we're
gonna have the norm of our function the
two norm is gonna at the terrible H
that's better H okay the norm of our
function is I take the inner product of
f of X with itself and I take the one
half power of that that's the norm of my
function and it's equal to the square
root of the integral from A to B of f of
X f of X conjugates DX and again what if
my function is real valued this is just
f squared of X super simple any function
I can do this with I can do this in
MATLAB numerically even if it's a
function I don't know how to integrate I
can integrate this numerically from A to
B no problem ok so this tells me what
the length of a vector is and so I can
use this to define the length of a
difference vector if I want to know how
close F and G are I just say well what's
the norm of F minus G and I can compute
how close are two functions so that's
why I care about doing this yeah
mentioning space Benedictus the hilbert
space is an infinite dimensional inner
product space so I have inner product
spaces of 2 D 3 D 5 D 10 B 20 D whatever
a Hilbert space is an infinite
dimensional inner product space usually
defined over complex numbers but but not
necessarily okay that's a good question
so let's say that I have a vector in two
space like I have two vectors in two
space how close are these two vectors
this is you know U and V so I just have
u minus V which is this one I add V 2
that I don't I can't do this in my head
but you have the difference vector this
is either u minus V or V minus u and I
want to know how long is that vector
that's how close these two vectors are
and how long this vector is is like
essentially the inner product of that
vector with itself square root it so I
want to know what is the what is this
vector u minus V inner product in with
itself and I need to take the square
root of that to get the actual length
into space okay so if you work it out in
coordinates x and y you'll find that you
really do need this square root to get
the actual honest-to-goodness length of
the difference between these two vectors
but this is a great question so this
motivates the next part let's actually
write this out for functions so let's
say I have two functions f of X and G of
X
are so how close are these two functions
okay so the way we do this is we take
and I'm assuming that these are real
valued functions because I don't like
conjugates so the how close these are I
take the norm of F minus G the l2 norm
this is the square root of the inner
product of these two vectors so it's you
know F minus G inner product F minus G
to the one-half power which is you know
I have this integral over the domain
where these functions are defined of f
of X minus G of x squared DX and I take
the square root of that so this is
exactly how close these two functions
are now this starts to make a little
more sense I'm literally taking the
difference between the two functions and
I'm sometimes adding up the squares of
the differences over all X and I'm
taking the square root this is just the
least squared error between F and G but
for a continuous function so let's draw
this out this is exactly what we what we
think this is exactly what we want for
the generalization of of an error norm
so let's say that I have a function okay
let's say that I have some function f
and I'm going to define this at a bunch
of points x1 x2 x3 x4 dot dot up to X n
so this is f n f1 f2 f3 f4 okay now
let's say that I have some other this is
4 X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 X N
let's say I have some other function G
now it's not exactly the same as F but
it's kind of close so I have G 1 G 2 G
3G 4G n if I just had these functions
sampled at a discrete set of points I
can create an F vector and a G vector
with n elements so I would have like my
F vector is equal to F 1 F 2 so on down
to F n my G vector is going to be
another vector G 1 G 2 down to G and
both of these are just normal n vectors
we feel pretty comfortable with n
vectors and so if I take the norm of the
difference of these two vectors then I
would say the norm of F minus G the two
norm is gonna what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this the square of the
differences at every point I'm going to
add them all up and I'm going to take
the square root that's how we do norms
that's how we've always done norms so
I'm gonna add up from k equals 1 to N of
FK minus gk squared square root now this
is looking a whole lot like our
continuous integral norm definition and
we could write this out all the way if
we want it it's the square root of you
know F 1 minus G 1 squared plus F 2
minus G 2 squared plus all the way up to
F and minus GN squared okay
so all that we're doing with this
infinite dimensional function space is
we're generalizing what we know is true
if we take the limit as Delta X goes to
zero okay I'm just gonna add up all of
these all of these these norms all of
these sum squared differences okay does
that basically make sense if this norm
of F minus G is small then F has to kind
of asymptotically be close to G they
have to be close at almost every X you
can name
not at all X there can be a couple of
finite differences but they have to be
discreet at only one point in X okay any
questions about this this idea of an
inner product spaces infinite
dimensional vector spaces this is not
easy this is not supposed to be easy or
super obvious right this took very smart
people hundreds of years to go from
thousands of years to go from you know
drawings in the sand and to space and
vector representations in 3-space to
infinite dimensional representations I
mean this is one of the culminations of
all of the history of mathematics is
thinking of a generalization of what we
think of vectors to infinite dimensional
function spaces and this is pretty
recent this happened within the last 200
years and this has been the basis for
most of the mathematical advances in the
last 200 years we couldn't have done
quantum mechanics without this function
space representation we would have never
had general relativity you wouldn't have
satellite communications without this
yeah just means complex conjugates so if
I have you know if G of X is complex
valued so that it has a real and an
imaginary part then this would be real G
minus I an add G
yeah you said that unless you made the
exception that you can only have
discrete values where for example it's
undefined credit versus segments of that
being undefined is that kind of what the
opposing view would be but in that case
wouldn't G not actually really affect
your face anymore
because it you wouldn't be able to
describe the whole face with it so if I
take the limit as Delta X goes to zero I
also probably should have something like
Delta X times this or 1 over N or
something like that
if I take the limit as Delta X goes to 0
then something pretty special happens
and I can actually have finite
discontinuities in G or finite kind of
weird values of G and even though at
those finite values I have a large
squared difference it's multiplied by an
infinitesimal Delta X so it goes to 0 so
I can still define these functions with
weird discontinuous stuff happening and
it turns out that Fourier series allow
me to actually represent these nasty
weird functions much better than I could
normally represent them if I have a
whole bar that were different than my f
then this would add up this would have
some finite you know non zero X range
and I would have a non zero
norm error they would be different sort
of wouldn't be able to include that
function in the in the space itself or
gnf are still both vectors in this
vector space it's just that they're
they're different they have a finite
normed difference if there's a finite
region where they're different if
there's one one special isolated
incidents where they're different that
doesn't really matter at least to this
norm definition to the hilbert space
it's a little weird we know that it
matters that this function has one place
where it's different they're different
functions but to this norm they're not
different so this tells you how
functions are the same up to a finite
number of weird discontinuity
discontinuities which is usually good
enough okay I should probably tell you
the last part of this lecture because I
have 15 minutes left
ok so the last part is pretty
interesting so we've talked about these
general notions of an inner product
space and a function space that's
infinite dimensional we call it a
Hilbert space ok I have lots of fun
facts about Hilbert maybe I'll tell you
next time ok so we have cosine and sine
functions that we use in our Fourier
series to represent a function now what
I'm gonna tell you is that those cosines
and sines essentially form vector
directions in an orthogonal they're
orthogonal vector directions in this
infinite dimensional hilbert space ok so
but what's interesting is that sines are
orthogonal to other signs right sine of
sine of M PI x over L is orthogonal to
sine of n PI x over L if and does not
equal M another way of saying that is if
I took the inner product of sine M PI x
over L and I take that inner product
with sine of n PI x over L this is going
to be 0 for all M not equal to n this is
0 if M is not equal to n and it's equal
to some finite number which I don't
remember it's equal to 2 pi if M does
equal n
yeah I think it's 2 pi it's a number you
can take the product of these you can
multiply them and integrate them and you
get some number out it's a real number
and this means that it's 2 pi times this
Dirac Delta function and and this just
is a function that's been defined so
that if M is equal to n it's 1 if M is
not and it's equal to 0 it's a
definition so signs are orthogonal to
other signs cosines are orthogonal to
other cosines but sines and cosines are
not orthogonal to each other you can
verify this really easily and you write
out the integral they're not equal to 0
or do it in MATLAB like you know I in
this homework sorry in this lecture I
include a little 8 line script that
tests if sines and cosines are
orthogonal and they're not in general
orthogonal ok so that's interesting
we've also seen that functions I can use
sines to approximate odd functions I can
use cosines to approximate even
functions but if I want to approximate a
generic function I need both sines and
cosines so I'm going about this long way
to tell you that sines are not enough
and cosines are not enough I need both
somehow ok to have this kind of to have
a full orthonormal basis for my infinite
dimensional vector space I need sines
and cosines but they're not orthogonal
to each other so we're going to
introduce this complex function so we're
going to use we're going to use e to the
I and X we're going to use these
functions which are cosines and sines to
represent all functions so this is equal
to remember this is coasts of NX plus I
sine of NX ok so what we're going to do
we're going to take our function f of X
and we're going to say that this
function is equal to an infinite sum
of some complex coefficient CN e to the
I and X so the CN is complex-valued and
I'm going to essentially plug this
formula in and I'm going to expand it
out so this equals the sum N equals
minus infinity to infinity of alpha and
plus I beta n times cosine and X plus I
sine and X if I were to find on some
interval from minus L to L I could have
made this divided by L or divided by PI
or whatever whatever interval I'm on
doesn't matter okay so this gets a
little nasty for a minute but then it
gets simple again so I'm going to break
this sum up into the positive part from
N equals 1 to infinity and the negative
part from N equals minus 1 to infinity
and the zero part so the zero part is
simple it's just alpha zero plus I beta
zero times
coast zero is one sine zero zero okay so
I have my positive sum from N equals one
to positive infinity which is how do I
want to do this
okay so I have alpha and coasts and X
yeah why don't you just do minus
infinity and not equal to zero so we
have alpha n cos NX minus beta n sign
and X plus I times beta and coasts and X
plus alpha and sign and X okay now half
of these indices are negative and the
other half are positive and for all of
the negative indices cosine of a minus
number is just coasts of that positive
number sign of a negative number is a
negative sign of that number and so you
can kind of get all of the details if
you work this out by hand I'm just going
to write out what this simplifies to
okay so we have alpha naught plus I beta
naught plus a sum from N equals 1 to
infinity of alpha of minus ends plus
alpha of ends times cosine NX plus beta
minus n minus beta sub n times sine of
NX and I have a second complex valued
sum from N equals 1 to infinity of beta
minus n plus beta n coast minus alpha n
minus alpha and of sine
okay this is just a really long horrible
crude expression for what f of X equals
if I expand it in this basis of e to the
I am X's these are functions these are
orthogonal functions that we're going to
see on Friday and this is what I get so
if f of X is real valued what can we say
about these coefficients A's and B's at
alphas and betas sorry
okay that is real-valued then this
imaginary term has to go to zero
uniformly which means all of these
coefficients have to go to 0 because
sines and cosines aren't going to do it
so that means that alpha minus N equals
alpha N and beta minus N equals minus
beta and remember that just says that C
of minus n that's minus alpha alpha
minus n plus a beta minus n which equals
alpha n minus I beta n which is the
complex conjugate of my nth coefficient
so my minus enth coefficient has to be
the complex conjugate of my nth
coefficient as long as f is a
real-valued function and what we're
gonna see on Friday so I'm gonna stop
here
what we're going to see on Friday and
you can read this in the notes to get
kind of a head start on what we're doing
we're going to show that this is truly
an orthogonal basis so fee and inner
product in with fee M is equal to zero
if and not equal to M and it's equal to
2pi if N equals M so this is an
orthogonal basis it's infinite
dimensional because I can do N equals 0
to infinity and this will be we'll be
able to write any well-defined function
f of X in this basis and that's how
we're going to we're gonna rewrite our
Fourier series in this kind of fancier
complex basis okay that's all for today
functions are infinite dimensional in
event infinite dimensional vector space
they have an inner product so we can
sell how close to functions are and I'm
claiming that these functions provide an
orthogonal basis in Hilbert space just
like our sines and cosines this is a
generalization of sines and cosines
these are orthogonal and they provide an
infinite dimensional basis
okay we're gonna see this more on Friday
and a much more concrete setting all
right good luck on the midterm I will
post it in the next ten minutes
you